THANK HEOU.ROM COLUMBUS, OHIO.IL
ON THIS REMARKABLE FIGHT T
BLCHIEF ANT'S THE BEST WAYTO PUT
MITCH McCOELS IS BETWEEN
RICK SCOTT AND MER A COMMENT THD
HAVE, J.D. VTHE FACT THAT THEYRO
PUT ALL THIS MEYO THE
COTT SAIINN D
TODAY INHEE VERY
PEOPLE RESPOLE LIN LASE ARW
THE MAJORITYHIS TIME BY
CANDIDATES.
TI TREASONOU
AUSE. MITCH McCONNELLPIPE DWIIM
>> I MEAN,HEIS NOT
L.
YOU HAVE DIF JIS HOW
THEY SHOULD GO ABOUT TRYING TOGA
SENATE.
D AWAY FROM
THE PRIMARY.TTINS THUM
AT MAGOF THE REPUBLICAPACONNELLH
HAD A SERIESF
RS OF HING A MORE TRADITIONALAT
CANDID SNE
ONED TO WIN OVER
INDEPENDENTS ANDOD.
BUT NOW YOU HA OF OTT FOR HOW
THAT THES
SENATE CANDIDATES AR'T WHERE AR.
YOU HAVE HAD CANDIDATE RSCHEL WA
HAVEN'T  KEEP UPY OF THE PARTY.
AS ISSHA
REPUBLICANS AND HAVE F
MORE ON DEMOCRATIC AGENDA,
ANDIDA STRUGGLED
AND THE CRITICISM  SEN  TOO., WT
COMMON, THEY'RE ALL POLITICA
GOT THESE TWHICH HEIN THERI.T T
McCONNELL ANRICK SCOTT, 'S
ATINTO>> THI FDA
QUESTION IN THE REBLY, HOWY ON
RN HOW
MUCH DO U O APPEALO
R VOTEONALD
S STRATEGY FROM 2016 AND20, TUR
IT WORKED FO
20T IN 2020, OBVIOUSLY.
BUT ISE REPUBLICAN PARTY IINAHAK
HE SAID LOOKNG TN.HEACOMMENTATO
Y HE'S GOING TO RELY ON THAT
ME.
NCRIZONA
THIS OUTSI MM THIS  NFIBETWEEN
WHETHER OR NEALLINHERE'S ALWAYS
UTCOO HOBLICANS GOING TO REUGGLC
PALIN, LRACET
NIGHT.
THERE HAVE BEE
IT'S ALASKA,E ARE
QUESS R YOU CAN READ
O MUCH WHAT ITANTH
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> YEAH, IT BU OE
IT'S N J PALINAC
ISOLATIOIS A REPEATED PLE.
YOU HAVE THE SPECIAL ECTION
RACE IYORK.
UA THE COUNTRY
DEMOCRATICHAS RISEN.
Y UNIVERSALLY .EEN THE BACKLASH
DEMOS.
SEEINBLNOG THE P
BECOMES NATIONEDAT THEAKVA OHIO
E AP IN THE LARGERS R